hello I'm Arnold Edward Morales rosselli  oh I live in Cochabamba Tiki fire in  Bolivia cochabamba Pinkie Pie yeah this  Cyrus a lot of mi familia being with my  family on the most of the time we hang  out in the kitchen Cena yes this is my  dad my mom and my sister  Lucy document i love Bolivian music my  favorite Bolivian band is lost carcass  i mispronounced foreign medio ambiente i  think one of the biggest problems is  environmental damage the lab well that  is the pollution of the air the land and  water  SI tengo miedo I'm afraid of snakes  there's nothing else really just snakes  is this is fearful thorough song I want  to be a swimming coach say professor in  fcso piscina this is the pool where I go  to train monday to friday between four  and five o'clock  you